Would you like a folk remedy?
no problem. What should I do?
You only have to answer the questions.
Several years ago,
I and a friend of mine went to the Scientology Complex in Los Angeles to see what this doctrine was; we were curious.
I spoke about the trip in one of the first episodes of this channel.
They toured us around the facility and introduced us to some of its nice members and we were given
Tests to determine personality, the test is called: the Oxford test for capacity analysis,
But it has nothing to do with Oxford University or any prestigious institution,
Was more than I imagined,
It contained 200 questions, including what appeared in this scene of the film
Director Paul Thomas Anderson: The Teacher (2012)
"Do you spend a lot of time at the bus station just for fun?"
"Do you have muscle spasms for no reason?" "Do you want to do what you are ordered to do?
Are you interested? Are you jealous? Are you scientific in your thinking? Are you honest? Are you unpredictable?
This treatment of the film looks to me better
The scenes in one of the best movies last ten years. Simple, brilliantly performed, and charming.
Which in turn is not wrong for filmmakers. If you are interested, the scene touches some of the real ideas of a method
Doctrine of Scientology
Anderson always stresses that the film was not an accurate re-cutting of the founding of Scientology,
The similarities between characters, sense and style are hard to overlook. For example, this scene
Reflects a fundamental activity in the science, called "listening". This word comes from a word meaning
"To listen". In this listening phase, the person who runs the session is called the listener, and the future person is called imperfect.
Because he himself did not get rid of his mind associated with a certain shock. In the teacher's film
The character of Lancaster Dodd was portrayed by Philip Seymour Hoffman, the listener, and Freddie, who was Joaquin Phoenix
Minus purity. The character of Dodd plays the role assigned by the student to the listener asking the imperfect questions in order to save him from
"Agrams". A term that means traumatic memories that are stored in the reactionary mind. Helps the listener minus the serenity to cheer him off
Traumatic experience. When he has a lack of clarity, or awareness
Positive awareness, the meeting ends. If this is somewhat like psychoanalysis for you
This is because it is. When the founder of Alamogia. Ron Hubbard, these methods in his book The Dianetics
I think that in his own mind he believes that he has embarked on a new approach in psychotherapy,
Something scientifically accurate and effective. Certainly, as we know, Dianetics is not an exact scientific book.
He has been rejected several times by all societies concerned with mental health, which has been classified as a fake science, and so is. But as we saw in the film teacher
There is no doubt that this listening process can give effect. "where is your mother?"
"I do not know..."
"again."
In this treatment scene, Dodd makes Freddy recognize several previous psychological trauma: the death of his father,
His mother's confinement in a sanatorium, his forbidden relationship with his aunt, and the times when he was killed in the war.
These shocks are used as a means of influencing
Ingram in the session:
Freddy is deserted for his love. As in psychoanalysis, Dodd achieves this
By initiating a process of reciprocity that tries to liberate the repressed or difficult to confront.
But the methods used are different. As critics have long believed, the method of listening that in theology goes beyond
Which in psychoanalysis, or therapy by talking, because it uses a form
hypnosis. "Say your name." "Freddy Cowell."
"again." "Freddy Cowell."
During this scene, Dodd works to make Freddy under his command. In the first part which was largely organized
Like a personal test, ask him several yes-or-no questions, making Freddy get used to this style of
The call and answer, staff repetition to urge Freddy to relax and focus. "Did your previous concerns bother you?"
"No." "Did your previous concerns bother you?"
"No..."
"Did your previous concerns bother you?"
"Um ... no." "Did your previous concerns bother you?"
Repetition is also important. Dodd tries to make Freddy
Concentrates on your previous failures. After this short session ends, Freddy insists on more and Dod agrees
But this time with Freddy warning not to blink, otherwise questions will start over.
This excess condition has a Freddie mind and with answers to the questions from the first part, begins to answer
"Have you had a sexual relationship with a relative?" "Yeah."
"From?" "My aunt." "Did you kill anyone?" "No." "Probably?" "no not me." "Did you kill anyone?"
"No." "How many times have you done with your aunt?" "three times." "where is she now?"
"I do not know."
"Would you like to have it again?" "No!"
With the style prepared by Dodd
Plus intensity, plus intensity, plus severity
What an escalation that made Freddy tense, and at the most charged moment,
Dodd interrupts Freddy's liquid style and closes his eyes.
The resulting feeling at this moment is real. Just like real hypnosis
As psychological therapy and psychoanalysis are real, because cognitive activity is essentially real and can be judged,
Manipulating it, and displaying it from several angles. Listening is the center of the science; it produces
A feeling of assimilation that convinces people that these roads are necessary for health.
This is the danger of science as well. I mean hypnosis for people looking for it.
But she flatly rejects hearing that employs hypnosis altogether.
For this reason, the people, like Freddy, who tried it without their knowledge are vulnerable to compulsive ideas, whether it is done
Maliciously
Or by someone who has not been trained properly; they can be persuaded that the church is absolutely right
They deserve the money and time they asked them to give.
"To clarify, all you have to do is show the other that he is able to ridicule his abilities or difficulties
Not to be completely aimless. Here you have memorized it.
I think that listening, as we saw in the teacher, is the best way
To "filter every person on earth." When this is your goal, there is no place to doubt your methods
When doubt is the essence of all forms of mental health.
We do not understand all the ways the mind works, and probably will not understand.
But psychotherapy and psychiatry, which work within a scientific society, has its ethics and protects against abuse,
Progress to be helped who can not keep pace with life.
They are not perfect, but they are much better than
Theology.